ce réveillon de noël a tourné au
cauchemar pour ces hommes et ces femmes
retenues en otages dans le magasin de
vins derrière moi voilà ce qu'on sait
assurément vicente santos est le
propriétaire de la boutique de
spiritueux noël par mois ça comme
qu'elle daniel sagem caissière vous
retenez de zama j'ai mon fils de 5 ans
la voiture de patrouille de carrelet en
contrebas de la route et semble avoir
une descenderie et pour finir eric noise
c'est peut-être pas le preneur d'otages
un fermer les stores asseyez-vous dû
commencer à agir comme avant explique
ces gentils merci qu'est ce que vous
faites à cette ville mon père vivait ici
j'espérais le retrouver son équipier lui
m'ont foutu en taule sans raison et fo
il avait de l'herbe et de quoi faire du
cristal mais j'ai acheté du déboucheur
l'herbe c'est à lui des serrures des
renforts vont bientôt arriver
ils ont un petit pois la place de la
cervelle et et vous l'avait relâché de
tirer on vous a tiré dessus non on n'a
pas tiré dessus j'ai dit arrête de tirer
qu'est ce que tu veux pour noël sortir
d'ici faites attention
nous ferons tout ce que nous pourrons
pour que les otages retrouve au plus
vite leurs familles
c'est quand le plan fait pendre une
machine à remonter le temps
[Musique]
du sel
vous êtes fort est dans un sale pétrin
on peut pas négocier avec un four et
arrête ton cinéma pine et débats samuel
l l'acte 1
[Musique]